foreign
ERS in Quebec's North have been
overwhelmed only able to fight about a
third of the fires that are burning
when they weren't battling on the ground
was Northeast of shibugomo Tuesday winds
moved at about 20 kilometers closer to
town
the mayor took to Facebook Tuesday night
to say the fire moved faster than
predicted and ordering an evacuation
people were told to gather as few
possessions as possible and move to
Robert about 250 kilometers away
seven thousand people tried to leave
almost together causing a bottleneck
followed by bumper-to-bumper traffic the
rest of the way what would normally be a
three-hour Drive turned into eight and
stretched through the night
the herbal arena is now a shelter for
about a thousand evacuees others are
staying with family or friends or in
hotels Quebec now has more than 11
000 people who've been forced from their
homes that number is likely to grow
the case of the town of chapet there
were evacuations last week people went
home and they may soon be told to
evacuate again
the province has right now according to
the premier about 520 firefighters and
150 soldiers over the next week help is
coming from other provinces and other
countries New Brunswick France United
States Portugal Spain and Mexico so we
are looking to increase the number to
about 1200.
now there is an issue with aircraft
Quebec has 11 tankers in the air with
six more on the way but Pilots are
closing in on the maximum they can fly
they have mandatory rest coming and the
aircraft have mandatory maintenance and
checks every 50 hours we cannot expect
that all the aircraft will be able to
fly full time every day
now the extra bodies are good news but
they're only a short-term solution the
situation is bad enough Quebec's
firefighting agency says it's likely to
need help All Summer Long Mike Armstrong
Global News